[Music]
come on
let's go let's do this come on otto
you're doing great let's go
timeout have you seen the score i know
i'm not getting a single shot on gotta
think positive
11-0
at least we had fun
i didn't have any fun
[Music]
have you have you seen my banana oh
i can't find it anywhere are you sure
it's not here
i'm sure i had a banana i actually saw
them there you have it exactly
[Music]
ah well done guys
footwork for three minutes
[Music]
and start
what's that popping sound
and change on second thoughts one more
minute
mika i think your spin needs a bit more
pop
oh yeah thank you
like that
[Music]
five minutes ago i was getting
everything on the table
okay coach look at this don't miss this
yeah i never miss your shots
[Music]
coach
[Music]
sometimes you have bad days
you missed it again
what yeah everything is going pretty
well here yeah it's pretty good here
what did you say this is it you're
playing keep playing
oh yeah yeah yeah let me go go play with
the other player just no there's yeah
it's auto is too good for you it's
player corner
chin up look to the sky player two
that's good
new guy
excellent
now we can start table tennis
left right left right left right left
right left right let's crawl
[Music]
perform yeah new guy perfect
okay this is ridiculous i'm out of here
continue when are we going to play
today's main exercise
over
under
backhand
forehand take cover
good to take cover
that's it all guys
come back
[Music]
no no you need to hit the last shot
here
but i want it
oh girl
i said harder okay come on i'll give you
a hard one
too
come on mika faster movement with your
hand
[Music]
stop fooling around
alright guys next exercise starts off
with a short serve short receive long
push diving shot instead of normal block
you do one with that the footwork has to
be a flowing motion spin it up loads of
spin and up to here cross down the line
cross and then short ball long ball and
down the line again backhand block
forehand loop counter attack fake shot
over there and then we come in with a
serve chop block
receive your own chop block receive one
more you do a cartwheel
[Music]
oh come on
come on
move move
[Music]
yes that's right it's looking good
keep going keep going
[Music]
what do you want
are you are you sure you want to come to
the table
[Music]
whoa
that was that was
impressive
[Music]
okay guys good session
let's pick up all the balls and finish
off
[Music]
okay i think that's everything
everything yes
[Music]
what is this
maybe there was one or two walls
[Music]
what are these
i have no idea how they got there i just
checked it and there was nothing
[Music]
this one was in the forest i can't
believe you didn't check it
why would we check the forest in the
forest
emil
this was in your bag
you missed one over here after
okay that has to be the last one yeah
definitely did you check the flying
balls flying balls yeah you gotta check
your firing ball
what
[Applause]
it is going well
can you can you give me some space and
then chin up chin up lift this
leg why and then lower lower lower
yeah
i got like this yeah i got it i got it i
got it no no no fast
and then you get the spin
oh
you know the combo we've tried
whenever you get the chance
okay let's go come on
[Music]
yes
[Music]
yes
good let's go let's go coach seven six
seven
[Music]
i'm behaving i'm behaving
remember
[Music]
ah
that's enough for today oh come on mikk
let's just finish off these balls just
these balls there are still a t left
here
[Music]
okay there are still a few more
how many how many balls do you have
that's a few left
come on keep
keep our k-pop
these are the last plus
come
on maker start for the last ones or
actually if you haven't heard we're
going to make the world's largest table
tennis racket made completely out of
chocolate if we reach 5 million
subscribers by the end of the year make
sure to subscribe so we can make this
happen
this is right
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
well done guys
just like my meatballs